[Música]
Bienvenidos a medio ambiente yo soy
María Clara calle una de cada tres
personas se enfrenta escasez de agua y
eso es una de las caras más difíciles de
la crisis climática el aumento de la
temperatura del planeta ha hecho que los
ciclos hídricos sean más impredecibles
con inundaciones más fuertes que
contaminan las fuentes hídricas y
conseguías más prolongadas que además
erosionan el suelo y reducen la
capacidad de absorción ante los riesgos
en América Latina se han creado 26
fondos de agua pues no en vano en la
región hay un tercio del agua dulce del
mundo y Colombia es el mayor país con
estos números de organizaciones en
Francia 24 conocimos agua somos el fondo
de Bogotá que promueve la protección del
recurso hídrico de más de 10 millones de
personas en la región capital
María Elena cambió la papa por el
ecoturismo y así cuida una de las
mayores fuentes de agua en Colombia los
páramos
esta campesina vive en el páramo de
Guerrero ubicado A las afueras de Bogotá
la capital sus 40 años en el campo le
han enseñado la gran cantidad de agua
que consumen los cultivos y la ganadería
y para los cultivos de papa va
dependiendo las fumigaciones o
aplicaciones que se le haga pongámosle
una fumigada en la semana y ahí se irían
más o menos unos 2000 litros de agua
esos 2000 litros ahora le pueden durar
entre 3 y 4 meses para el consumo de
quienes van al airbnb que queda en su
predio Y aunque no es la dueña Si recibe
una mensualidad con la que compra la
comida para toda su familia y de paso
protege el bosque alto andino Ese es el
objetivo de agua somos el fondo de agua
de Bogotá región
básicamente lo que le estamos diciendo
un propietario es
seda un poco de su uso de la tierra para
un objetivo de conservación o de
restauración y nosotros le vamos a
ayudar a que nunca sacrifique sus medios
de vida ese trabajo con las comunidades
lo dividen en tres programas mi páramo
agua por el futuro y mi páramo emprende
y así conservar casi 4.000 hectáreas de
bosque pero por ejemplo agua por el
futuro o agua por el planeta es un
proyecto ya crean ya que realmente su
intención es medir regulación hídrica
metros cúbicos regulados es trabajar con
menos predios previos mucho más grandes
donde realmente hacemos un monitoreo en
términos de la conservación del Bosque y
como este bosque ha cambiado a lo largo
del tiempo para que finalmente
inversionistas Como por ejemplo
coca-cola u otros puedan venir a hacer
confesiones ambientales a través de
bonos de carbono además de promover
cultivos distintos impulsan innovaciones
como la moda la prueba es el vestido de
Andrea el fin es que los campesinos se
queden en los páramos un ecosistema en
el que Colombia es rico al tener la
mitad de los páramos andinos del mundo
lo primero es que los páramos son
enormes tanques de agua los páramos lo
que hacen es generar agua cuando no hay
lluvia la guarda la retienen y la
sueltan lentamente cuando no hay lluvia
eso es lo que se llama regulación
hídrica su mayor amenaza es la crisis
climática Y si los páramos de Colombia
se pierden el agua del 70% de la
población estaría en riesgo pero más que
cifras para los campesinos es un legado
ancestral que hay que cuidar
pero en otras partes del mundo el agua
es cada vez más escasa el río Colorado
uno de los principales causas de Estados
Unidos enfrenta la peor sequía en más de
mil años y con ellos se ponen riesgo el
agua de más de 40 millones de
estadounidenses Y es que los dos
embalses de Agua Dulce más grandes del
país y que salen del Colorado están en
niveles históricamente bajos por eso las
autoridades federales le pidieron a los
siete estados por donde atraviesa el río
que diseñaran un plan para reducir el
consumo en un 40% del flujo total pero
los gobiernos estatales incumpliaron el
plazo y todavía no hay una ruta la
historia es de Andrés triviño
100 años después un acuerdo entre siete
estados de Estados Unidos para dividir
las aguas del poderoso caudal del Río
Colorado se ve amenazado los últimos 22
años se han registrado los niveles más
Bajos en 1.200 años para la comunidad
científica la desigualdad en la división
ha sido la mayor causante de esta
situación
[Música]
hubo dos fallas principales En el pacto
del Río Colorado tal como se negoció la
primera fue a quien dejó fuera
la otra gran falla del pacto fue que se
basó en estimaciones infladas de lo que
realmente estaba disponible para dividir
entre los estados
el río Colorado uno de los más
importantes para Estados Unidos nace al
norte del estado que lleva su mismo
nombre y alguna vez desembocó con fuerza
en el Golfo de California el lago meat y
el lago Powell los dos embalses más
grandes del país se abastecen de este
río Aunque actualmente tienen una
reserva del 27% cada uno para el 2000
ambos embalses rondaban el 95%. Durante
los últimos meses los estados que se
abastecen del río se han visto obligados
a realizar cortes de agua por su parte
funcionarios federales han pedido que se
reduzca el uso de sus aguas en un 15%
del próximo año una medida sin
precedentes
los desafíos en el río Colorado son
claramente evidentes hoy lo sabemos
porque durante el último medio siglo el
río no ha corrido regularmente hacia el
mar lo sabemos porque hemos estado
observando estos embalses gigantes que
almacenan el agua del río y disminuyen
poco a poco año tras año
el futuro para recuperar el caudal del
río cada vez parece más difícil según
datos del censo de Estados Unidos
Arizona Utah y Nevada se encuentran
entre los 10 estados de más rápido
crecimiento aumentando la necesidad de
abastecerse del Río
la sequía también golpea gran parte de
México especialmente en el norte en
julio el 62% de los municipios mexicanos
enfrentaban escasez hídrica según la
Comisión Nacional del Agua la ciudad que
más ha padecido esto es Monterrey en el
estado de Nuevo León allí las lluvias
han estado por debajo de la media desde
2015 y la población en el área
metropolitana se quien duplicó al pasar
de 1,1 millones de habitantes en 1990 a
5,7 millones en 2020 según el Instituto
Nacional de estadística y geografía las
consecuencias son que en junio las
autoridades advirtieron que el agua
estaba garantizada solo durante seis
horas al día pero luego llegó la otra
cara de los extremos climáticos en
septiembre las Fuertes lluvias
provocaron desbordamientos de ríos y
ahora están esperando que los sedimentos
bajen para poder abastecer las reservas
y así llegamos al final de nuestra
Crónica ambiental Vean este y más
programas en Flash 24.com
[Música]